brexit polls the pollsters have got it
wrong again the 2014 US congressional
elections polls where did the Democrats
in the White House get this one polls in
Israel Greece Scotland wrong wrong and
wrong in any election here if you watch
cable news at least according to a new
poll latest wave of swing state polling
or read any news outlet or even take a
peek at Donald Trump's Twitter feed
polls are constantly referenced as if
they are gospel but every poll needs to
be taken with a grain of salt because
polling is an inexact science and can in
many cases lead to incorrect results so
here's the situation scientific polling
started with one man in 1932 George
Gallup he conducted a poll for his
mother-in-law who was running to be
Secretary of State in Iowa his polling
was accurate and she won but he still
got some predictions wrong remember this
headline one of the biggest election
headline blunders of all time was the
result of incorrect polls including
gallops methods were refined to become
more accurate and as they did polls grew
exponentially today in the US there's
Gallup Rasmussen Quinnipiac YouGov
Reuters even yours truly Bloomberg
conducts them the list goes on and on
but it's getting harder and harder to
trust their accuracy
one reason the cellphone because of a
ban on cell phone autodialing all calls
to cell phones must be made manually
which is not only time consuming but
expensive also since anyone receiving a
call on their cell can see who is
calling they tend to simply just not
answer the pollsters call few
researchers response rate in 1997 36
percent in 2012 9 % the low response
rates means it's becoming harder to get
accurate responses so analysts are more
likely to trust aggregations of polls
like those created by 538 Real Clear
Politics and HuffPost pollster as they
don't just focus on one poll
now here's the argument given the doubts
about the accuracy of polls pundits and
politicians may feel increasingly free
to skew the narrative any way they want
resulting in exchanges like this but you
guys are down and most of them pollsters
say more time is needed to adjust
sampling techniques in a mobile phone
era using the actual demographics of
voters and election day in the meantime
some think that polls are good for
democracy with the justification that
more people might vote that they didn't
think the results were preordained